hello everybody my name is nyan i'm the
black female engineer i provide content
for new and inspiring software engineers
and i went apartment hunting last
week yeah last week i went apartment
hunting i'm moving to los angeles
which is wild to me i've wanted to move
to los angeles for a very long time i'm
moving
for a job i have a new job as a software
engineer
in the animation realm in the
entertainment realm and so i need a
place to live i'll be moving in a couple
of weeks
shoot oh my gosh i'm moving in like two
weeks oh my gosh
yeah moving in like two weeks i start my
job in about a month and so i decided to
take you all along with me i'm going to
break this up so that
you get everything you want out of this
video and so i'm going to start off
with my own budget and my own you know
needs and wants of an apartment
then i'll go into the different tours
and we'll talk about each tour
and then close it off and so look at the
bookmarks
on this video and you can fast forward
to whichever part you're most interested
in but let's start off with what i was
looking for so my budget was in the 1500
to 2 000 range ideally i didn't want to
pass that thousand dollar ceiling i was
primarily looking at places in korea
town
and downtown los angeles i would have
loved looking
in places in hollywood as well but with
the
size i was looking at apartments at and
everything
i just didn't find anything online that
i even wanted to tour
in that price range and so sadly i kind
of had to
let go of that dream um i primarily
looked at apartments via
apartments.com and westside rentals and
so i'll link those
two below if you also are going to be
apartment hunting
soon and so yeah what were my needs and
what were
my wants pretty much my number one need
was
laundry on site if not in the unit
itself
and the unit itself i guess was a very
deep want
but for the right building and right
neighborhood and if everything else was
amazing
i could live with just laundry in
building and so really this was a big
non-negotiable like
yeah i lived in new york before i've had
the experience of
going to laundromats and everything and
i don't i
don't like the inconvenience of it and
so i really wanted it
at least at least at least in the
building
my second need was it needed to be at
least 600 square feet
i really didn't care if it was a studio
or one bedroom
as long as 600 square feet i currently
live in a studio that's about 515 square
feet
and it's a studio but i'm i'm looking at
it it's a studio but it feels like a one
bedroom because
right behind like right here there's
this
wall that separates the bedroom and
living room and the only thing missing
is
a door which is why it's considered a
studio and not a one bedroom
but i've loved this space and to me for
just
me myself and i it is more than enough
space for me the reason i wanted to
upgrade to 600 square feet is because i
wanted
an actual office corner
like a legitimate office it didn't need
to be a whole room but a legitimate
space
for an office since i'll be primarily
work from home or
hybrid from the sounds of things and so
i wanted to have a really nice space
dedicated to that so yes 600 square feet
studio or one bedroom i really didn't
care my third need was
updated appliances i needed
a nice updated kitchen and the nice
updated
bathroom those are things i really care
about um i really don't like
older looking styles and ovens and
stoves and countertops and things like
that i really
like things to look more modern and for
me that was quite a big need and then
lastly lots of natural light lots of
natural light
my current spot gets tons of natural
light
and it truly makes me so happy every
single day when i go to the kitchen
i look and i am just
overwhelmed with light i don't even turn
my lights on until like 8 p.m y'all
because of this big window i have
and it's west facing and so it's so
perfect
and so i really needed that in my next
apartment because
i am a person who can very much be
affected
um my mood can be affected by
sunlight sunlight and weather and so i
really wanted to have as much access to
that as possible now for
my wants and i'm looking at my laptop
because that's where my notes are and my
wants really were
dishwasher i don't really care about
dishwasher but
with my need of having updated
appliances in a nice kitchen
i imagine a dishwasher would be thrown
in there but in terms of just writing
things down i really didn't don't care
for a dishwasher
um laundry and unit private balcony
again
access to that sunlight and weather and
just
yeah lifting up my mood especially if
i'm work from home
being able to just access the outside
whenever i wanted to
near a park that would be a great want i
currently
live near park and it has been a game
changer and a nice
neighborhood nice neighborhood because i
care about where i live i care about
you know what's going to go on here at
3am when i'm
walking back home from wherever from
work
or maybe not 3am but you know when once
the sun goes down i don't want
to or i want to minimize my feelings of
unsafety and unrest
but because of where i live and the
neighborhood i'm in
and so i really wanted a nice
neighborhood
but i put it towards a wand because
depending on different things i could
budge a little bit here and there but
yes i want a nice
neighborhood okay so now let's go into
the actual apartment search this is just
part one there will be two parts
released
for today for next week so make sure you
subscribe
and put those reminders on so no let's
look at that first
[Music]
apartment
tell me
[Music]
um
so this apartment was priced at two
thousand twenty dollars a month
at around 755 square feet and so
definitely like a lot cheaper in terms
of
what i got for square footage but i
wasn't a fan
of the layout as you can see the kitchen
was
in like tucked away in like what i would
think would be kind of like a hallway
and so i didn't really like that layout
but i loved
the updated kitchen and the updated
bathroom did you see that bathroom did
you see that sink
in the bathroom i just was blown away by
that i love the cabinets i loved
the finishes so much and just in general
the apartment itself i really really
liked that big window was amazing
because of course it
provided a lot of natural light
especially because that
apartment was west facing so that would
be amazing amazing amazing and so in
general i
could make do with that floor plan
because i just loved that modern look
so much but in terms of the building
itself
it definitely was an older building and
it didn't really have
a lot of facilities provided
there was a rooftop but it really was
just like i don't even know
this little square that was able to fit
only like
two lounge chairs and a grill and so it
wasn't really
anything special and i mentioned how
much i loved that gorgeous window
but the thing is the apartment was
located in not the nicest of
areas it was in downtown los angeles and
so it wasn't in the
nicest of areas in downtown and so i
wouldn't even really
like what i was looking at you know what
i mean and so
those are a few things that i needed to
consider
but in all in all in terms of the
apartment itself i
really liked um the overall look and
feel of it other than the floor plan
now that being said i was able to tour
a different floor plan of theirs in the
same building that also would be
available for me to move into
so let me show you that real quick
before i go into everything else i
liked and disliked
[Music]
as mentioned this unit was in the same
building as
the previous unit you just saw and i
loved this floor plan
so much more and for prices it was 1970
a month
hundred and seventy dollars for 642
square
feet and i loved this apartment
especially because of that divider
a lot of people might not like it but i
actually really appreciated it because
it provided
a division between the living room and
the bedroom because
where i would imagine the bedroom would
be for me is past
that divider and so it also was
a studio and so i just liked that
separation
and just the floor plan in general it
also was west facing with that gorgeous
window
gorgeous appliances gorgeous kitchen and
bathroom i still
am thinking about that bathroom that
sink those tiles i'm still thinking
about
it all and so i really loved that with
this specific
apartment with this specific unit so i
already appreciated
the cost of the apartment given the
square footage
but on top of it they were offering 12
months of free
parking which for the
all of the apartments i've looked at
would cost between 150 to 300
a month for me which is like a whole
nother bedroom that's like adding a
whole nother bedroom
to your apartment and so that's wild to
me and i will
be bringing my car and so the fact that
they were offering 12 months free
parking was insane
insane to me and so i
loved this unit but really the biggest
thing i would
be focusing on and considering was that
location
piece when envisioning my walk home from
pretty much anywhere
it the surrounding area is a bit of an
eyesore
with you know trash just the area it was
in
wasn't great because downtown l.a has
parts of it where it's not the best it's
not the most
aesthetic but then they have parts that
look so majestic
so beautiful so glamorous and so i was
in this apartment in the former and so
those would be things i would need to
consider let's now go on to the next
[Music]
apartment
so
[Music]
the second apartment i loved it was so
beautiful
so just spacious and had all this
natural light
it was 1990 per month 1990
and it was in koreatown and as you can
see it was a very updated
apartment the property manager actually
told me that
that one i saw the one in the video has
actually
never been resided in and so i would be
the very first person to rent it
out which was a huge huge plus for me
and
i think if you look closely at some of
the things you can actually still see
like plastic and all these different
things still there
and so i loved that so much
it had washer dryer in unit and i'm glad
that
the video was able to pick up how much
natural light it got it was east facing
so i'd get a nice amount of lights i
really
loved that and in terms of the building
itself the apartment i believe
has only been up or only been open for
about
two years the entire building and so
it's very new and
their facilities were insane i've never
heard facilities like this so
let me list them out for you it was they
had a community room
they had a rooftop pool they had a movie
theater
they had a gym and a karaoke room
like what what
what and so i was truly blown away
by all of the things that were offered i
can't remember if i already said this
but it was 607
square feet and so right at the you know
minimum square feet for me and it was
all open as you can see so
no legit you know bedroom or anything
which i'm
truly fine with but i really appreciate
this apartment
a lot now the things i didn't appreciate
so much
was the location so it was in korea town
but i didn't like the actual street it
was
on the actual block so it was on the
corner of the street
and on that exact corner there was all
this trash all this just like
dirt and just uncleanliness going
on and so that really just was
i was not a fan of and i took some time
to walk around the block a little bit
and i didn't like the block i really
didn't like
the neighborhood specifically that it
was in and so that
was quite the con for me and i didn't
like that it was more removed from
downtown los angeles
that really is where i was trying to be
as much as possible because
i've never lived downtown downtown
anywhere before right now i live
about 10 minutes from downtown and so i
really wanted that experience that
20-something experience of
living downtown in a big city and
everything so
that also was a con how it's a little
bit far removed but it's not by that
much just like a 10 minute drive so
nothing crazy
but yeah those were my two cons but
other than that
i just loved the apartment and the
building
and so yeah now let's go to the next
[Music]
apartment
so
[Music]
so for me this apartment was okay it was
1957. a month
for 707 square feet however i didn't
really
like how much older things were the
finishes were
the appliances the kitchen was all right
but i
did not like the bathroom at all at
oh oh my gosh and that's something like
kitchen and bathroom are things that are
pretty important to me especially
because
that's where you can see the age of an
apartment pretty well
and so i was not the biggest fan
i was not a fan of the location the
location was in an area that was kind of
just a bit of an eyesore it was in
downtown los angeles
and it was just not the best location
not really somewhere
i would love to go home to every single
day or walk home to every single day or
every other day or whenever i walk home
because it's work from home and i
stay home all the time but yeah whenever
i
chose to go out and exercise my legs a
little bit
i would like something more aesthetic
a little bit more aesthetic to look at a
little bit more pleasing to the eye and
this really wasn't
that the building however had amazing
facilities they had
this gorgeous rooftop and an amazing
like events room
that you could rent out and have all
these
gorgeous glamorous piece of china and
just it was gorgeous it was very very
beautiful they had these really cute
details
um to the building because the building
i think was almost 100 years old if not
over 100 years old
and so it had fun little details here
and there from
the elevators and the finishings of that
to
little libraries headed around and all
of that and so i really liked the
character of the building so
much but when it came to the apartment
itself i wasn't
that great of a fan one thing the
apartment really did have going for it
though as you can see was
amazing natural light and so i really
appreciated that
but i also didn't like how there was no
washer dryer in the unit and it was just
on site and for me to be fine with
on-site
i kind of need to have everything else
kind of perfect for me to be okay with
washing dryer not in unit and so that
was just not the case
here and so that was pretty
disappointing yeah
let's yeah after my apartment hunt was
over i was able to
sign a lease so i do have a place based
on the videos
you either see here today or next week
in my part two and so put in the
comments below
do you think you saw the apartment that
i decided to go with do you think you
saw my future home in this video
and in general what was your favorite
because like
different things matter to different
people and i totally understand that so
i would love to hear
what things matter most to you and what
things what apartment just was your
favorite so
don't forget to subscribe please like
this video it helps me out a lot
and thank you so much for just being
here so no
see you all next week bye